well the osbornes join me now well most
of them because my old friend Sharon of
course is still in makeup which is the
least surprising news of the Millennium
but the three Legends in front of me are
there on time the great Ozzy Osbourne
the great Jack Osborne the great Kelly
Osborne welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored
yeah I mean that was the last one to get
up this morning can I just say that have
you waited to get ready you know that
pierce well Aussie having spent four
years working with your wife on
America's Got Talent I'm very familiar
with waiting for Sharon
earlier in her life
well you have and let's start with you
Aussie because I'm thrilled to have you
on on the show we called this show Piers
Morgan uncensored and when we named it
that I did actually think what would
happen when we finally get Ozzy Osbourne
live on the show how committed to being
uncensored could we be so I need to get
from you Aussie a solemn promise that
you're not going to get me banned from
the airwaves
are you promising you're not going to
get impaired from the airwaves oh no no
no no okay but I'll get you back just
just fine just a good old finding we're
gonna get through a whole lot of stuff
uh in the show tonight but Aussie let me
start with you uh how are you you've
been through all this health uh well
I've I've finally had my last proceeded
two days ago
uh I can't believe I'll come to the end
of it I'm still back up uh the Mind
thing is over now I'm done with this
surgery but it's been five years of
absolute hell for me and the family my
my family my family have been so
supportive
I couldn't have done it without it it's
been really a bad scene I have
Parkinson's but I never think about it
yeah and I think that's the biggest
misconception is like so many people
think you know what's happened with Dad
over the last five years is a result of
like Parkinson's but it's really it was
the neck injury in the fall that he took
in 2019. so well actually I was gonna I
was gonna talk about this because in
fact it goes back even further doesn't
it we'll come to the Parkinson's in a
moment Aussie but if you go back it
actually goes back to when you had that
horrendous quad bike crash in 2000. yeah
well I I did I just got up and carry on
but I had a broken
my neck yeah and I carried on working
with it for until so I didn't fall
and then it just everything came undone
you know
and then you get Parkinson's and the
state of the Parkinson's I was listening
to your podcast oh blimey get some tech
issues of it the the the condition of
your Parkinson's right now was he from
what you were saying in the podcast is
that as long as you take the medication
it's pretty tolerable
P2 or something which is a gymnastic
thing well I don't know
look I don't get up in the morning
you know I don't gripe on it again
if you're still moving you ain't gonna
be dead
am I detecting a rustling there to your
right jack that your mother might have
joined us yes yes yes
thank you thank you for maintaining your
reputation for always being late
I know I know can't help it I had to do
the washing up
so Sharon how are you yes
yes I'm good my darling missing you and
missing England yeah well we're going to
come to that actually and whether you're
going to come back here or not but for
on on Aussie's Health it's great to see
the great man looking so well actually
um but I know it's been a huge thing for
you as a family the Aussie's been
through this horrible stuff with his
back the Parkinson's obviously as well
and as a result he's not been able to do
what he loves most and that's touring
and you know being a massive rock star
what's it be like for you Sharon as the
matriarch of the family to to be through
the last few years with Aussie like this
so many people can relate you know who
has a partner whether it's the wife or
the husband that's not well it changes
your whole life you know you suddenly go
you're off in another Direction and your
life changes so drastically it's um
it's it's really hard especially in the
Summers because you know it's every
summer Aussie works and goes out and do
festivals and you know we're traveling
all over the world and for the last five
years we've been our life has changed
you know dramatically but on the other's
hand it's great that I've had Aussie at
home for five years he's driving me
crazy but we've been together every day
for five years you know what's funny I
mean what viewers probably won't know
but when I did America's Got Talent with
you for all those years we quite often
have dinner and Kelly I want to bring
you in here because one of my favorite
ever Osborne stories involved you which
was a dinner I think it was in Miami and
it was me your mum and dad you and your
boyfriend at the time Luke I think it
was and uh anyway you you suddenly
announced halfway through that you were
effing bored and that you were both
leaving you then departed from the uh
the room went out the back of the
restaurant and then you both dropped
your trousers outside a moonied through
the window at the three of us left
behind the boring old Stooges and all I
could think was the Aussie and Sharon
Osborne are two of the most outrageous
people I've ever met and they've now
been branding boring by their own flesh
and blood and the real outrageous one in
this family is that the torch had moved
to you Kelly
I I do think that it didn't move to me I
grabbed it and ran with it
much to my own self-demis but it I it
was a boring dinner so I left and made
it more fun on my way out it was not a
boring dinner we were all being very
entertaining albeit not for you
oh yeah I remember that in Miami yeah
weren't we at the Viceroy yeah I can't I
think it was but it was it was a it was
a fabulous dinner until you two uh
mooned us all I remember is your parents
shopped faces as YouTube moonied through
the window and I found that one of the
funniest things I'd ever watched was the
outrage from your parents at this
Behavior
had usually it's the other way around
outraged uh Kelly you're looking great
over the fact that our parents just said
thank you yeah how's how are you how's
your health how's your life
I'm really good my life is amazing I am
a new mother and just every single day
that I get to take care of my baby and
be his mum is the greatest gift I've
ever been given in my life and you you
looked at it and you looked at a long
life of turbulence with your rock star
father and decided that you too would
have to get together with a rock star
well when you think about it it's all I
know
and there must be something about the
life I mean I always wanted to be a rock
star obviously I'm a frustrated rock
star already but uh there's probably a
truth to that isn't it it's a world that
you all know so well right so actually
whilst it may seem strange to other
people on the outside to think well why
would you get together with a rock star
to me it was like well why wouldn't you
because that's a world you know so well
it's it's it's so true you know we
become like like anything you get your
own little bubble and you're surrounded
by the people that you work with all the
time so you know it's it's very natural
that that would happen it's the same as
me if I'd have married
um an accountant or a lawyer that would
have been like well where did I find you
do you know do you know what I'm saying
it just wouldn't seem right somehow and
Jake you're looking great I know you've
been clean a long time
um you've had your health issues uh
multiple sclerosis but you're looking
extremely well you're taking part in
various TV shows which are sort of Iron
Man stuff
um so how are you are you doing well
yeah I'm doing great yeah I'm totally
I'm hanging in there just fine like it's
uh you know kind of similar to Dad like
as far as the MS goes it's you know I've
kind of most days I wake up and I kind
of forget that it is a part of my life
at this point so it's uh you know I I'm
not slowing down at all which is great
you've also got four daughters now the
only other person I know with four
daughters is my my recently retired army
brother Jeremy he's got four girls so
I'm very familiar with the particular
endurance test that you may be going
through jack
oh yeah there's a lot of emotion in my
household so much emotion but it must be
great fun I mean I was exactly Envy my
brother I've got three boys and a girl
now um but when I see my brother with
his girls they are all doting on their
dad I mean you you are going to get very
lucky with all these girls taking care
of you I think
absolutely I love it and I you know and
I I
think boys are great they're fun but
they seem to break everything and you
know my girls just kind of want to hang
out have cuddles and like do cute things
and I'm totally fine with that
now also you'll be sitting there
patiently listening to all this the
question I've got for you is when you're
now a grandfather to all these uh kids
do you change nappies I mean are you a
reformed I know you didn't when you were
a dad or no but do you know no
no
he runs for the Hills
no not a singer if Aussie had to change
his diaper it would end up on the head
or something you wouldn't know what to
do with it
would you like to be your granddad
right my I love my grandchild
do you think you're a better grandfather
are you a better grandfather than you
were father Aussie do you think
not really
I tried am I asking the wrong person
here I can see the others laughing no I
no he is an incredible grandfather and
my little boy lights up every time I've
got grandchildren in England I don't see
much you know yeah yeah you've got five
four five you've got 10 grandkids wow